each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
every one for me is a great pleasure to
introduce the Speaker of the second talk
of our mini seminar today professor
Walter Kellerman I don't think that I
have to do long introductions here he is
well known as valuable contributor to
audio in signal processing we know that
he is currently chairman of the
technical community of audio
electro-acoustic sofia tripoli signal
processing society he is a distinguished
lecturer in I Tripoli
but for many of us of us he's just
walter Kellerman the enthusiast who
brings new algorithms new ideas
constantly tries to improve this or that
particular algorithm in acoustic echo
cancellation in my suppression in
microphone arrays constant participants
of the conference we will have to
participate and to take part of so
without wasting too much time professor
Kellerman has the floor thank you even
for this very nice introduction and as
all of you know the main work is usually
done by the students and this is the
list of students I want to recognize
first before I start my talk and some of
you will know robot Eichner and I he
promised to join us today he is with
Microsoft since about a year and it's
working on an acoustic signal processing
which is the first line of the title the
next one is of course some password but
the main thing is of course the
multi-channel aspect of what we want to
look at in this talk and I would like to
start with a brief introduction and I
apologize already that it's not going to
too much into details in this talk I
would like to focus on the general scope
of this area and also on some specific
solutions of course in order to make you
believe that something works at least so
the goal is pretty simple it's an ideal
seamless human machine interface which
means these users here in an acoustic
environment should be untethered and
they should be mobile and we foresee a
number of loudspeakers and a number of
microphones to do some signal processing
and the signal processing should fulfill
the following tasks namely first it
should reproduce signals for the
listeners at their ears in the way they
like it or we would like them to listen
to and the other way the other tasks are
basically to capture source signals and
to determine the source position so you
see already we have a reproduction
problem and we have a signal acquisition
problem and the the fact that it's a
problem is due to the acoustic
environment here which creates feedback
between the loudspeakers and the
microphones we have reverberation and
reverberation comes in two flavors here
usually and Sean McDonough alluded to
that already of course we have the
reverberation here when picking up the
loads the microphone signals and the
second flavor is the reverberation that
we hear when we are listening to
loudspeaker signals and basically this
is something which we mostly ignore but
I will come to that later
it's a perceptual thing that needs to be
addressed in reproduction systems
especially if it's high-quality and
finally we have of course noise in
interference and we want to address all
these three problems in the following
and one of them real problems is that in
many scenarios you have all of these
problems together simultaneously so
signal processing needs to look at it
simultaneously you all know many of
these applications I categorized them
into two classes one is basically
hands-free equipment for
telecommunication and what I call here
natural human machine interaction which
includes of course speech recognition
and you find them in mobile phones
Carrick cars with desktop computers but
also for telepresence systems and this
is an area which I especially like
because there you may have more money to
spend on microphone and loudspeaker
arrays which is not the case for example
in cars and mobile phones and of course
then if there is all these smart in
applications like smart meeting room
smart homes and sometimes you look at
museums and exhibitions as well the
second class is audio communication and
now this means here we look at equipment
for stages and for recording studios and
also virtual acoustic environments for
example virtual concert halls or tele
teaching studios and with regard to the
tele teaching studios you may think of
musicians practicing in two different
places together this is a very nice
problem there you can add this the
requirements are pretty tough and that's
something to look at in the future which
is very challenging and of course there
is a more secretive application which is
surveyance and as you can see I don't
put too many sub items here for the same
reason okay let me show you a few
microphone arrays which we built and it
actually when I joined the university in
erelong and we started with a project on
microphone arrays for laptops with Intel
at that time and here you see a
microphone array of eight mics which
will be used for beamforming in the
following and to illustrate the be
following algorithms in the sequel as
well then actually robot I can I worked
in a European project groups where the
environment got a little more
challenging namely adverse hands-free
communication for emergency cars like
fire brigade cars where there's a lot of
noise there's a lot of tension where the
speakers and obviously this is only a
reference microphone so this is not to
be used in practical applications at
that point so the microphones are here
we use microphone arrays also for
interactive TV applications now in a
recent European project entitled its it
and what you see here we have a large
array and you see logarithmically space
sensors here along a long line actually
there the whole array is about 1.5
meters so that's for large screen TVs as
well and here you see another
application for localization actually in
a parking garage I
hope the image is not too dark for you
so that you can see the array here and
here and this is meant for localization
purposes in highly reverberant
environments like parking garages
another application of surveillance
would be public spaces and here you see
another microphone away with the total
of six senses and here we have a very
small one which is also used for
multiple source localization it's only
about ten centimeters of die and
basically you can use it for
surveillance purposes so that you
immediately can steer a camera to when
somebody smashes that we know for
example it's for maced mostly for bad
guys right and that's of course I only
show the civil applications here okay
then I would I always like to show a
picture which is a microphone array
which I did not build that's the one by
Gary Elko here and I always use this in
order to illustrate what also could be
done but has been forgotten over past
years this is an array which basically
is meant for communication between
several auditoría and this was at the
high times of Bell Labs when they built
this 360 element array for basically
picking up the sound in the auditorium
and being able to broadcast questions to
the other auditorium as well so you did
not need a person to run around and put
him a microphone to the asking people so
you could use this microphone array and
that was actually back from the 80s and
during my PhD time more or less exactly
20 years ago we digitized that by
putting a PS DSP just behind each sensor
so and it was one of the first
generation floating-point DSPs some of
you may know on the with reproduction
side I yeah
that was actually originally it was full
bandwidth for audio but we only use
telephone bandwidth for evaluation so
it's 8 kilohertz in that yeah oh that
was a lot of data actually here though
we had we had cubic meters of hardware
you may ask Kerry for the details okay
then on the reproduction side we had a
look into wave field synthesis for a few
years now and actually this work is
mostly done by rudolf Rammstein which
also with our chair and he's basically
trying to recreate acoustic wave fields
not just in a sweet spot but in an
extended area and this for example would
mean here in this area which is enclosed
by this by this rectangle but you can
have these loudspeaker is also in that
fashion basically you use these panels
and each of these panels has an
essentially an 8 channel loudspeaker so
you have 8 exciters behind these panels
and this was supported by the European
Union also within the project of Caruso
a while ago this is just for
introduction now let me move over to the
more generic stuff in terms of equation
and I would like to look at the
fundamental problems that we face here
for reproduction and acquisition and
then I would like to show some advances
in our group in mainly in the area of
signal acquisition and that looks at
multi-channel acoustic echo cancellation
at beamforming I apologize for using
beam for me but we also look at line
signal processing and then you may think
of all your higher orders higher order
statistics and we published a while ago
a concept which we think is quite
generic and we entitled it to any con
that can be used for saw separation D
reverberation and source localization
and actually you can see it as more
general theory
incorporating supervised filtering like
adaptive filtering and beamforming like
echo cancellation in beamforming as well
and finally I will briefly look at the
source localization in the wave domain
and then I will come back to one of
these examples of microphone arrays that
you've seen already
so let me first start with the way we
describe these problems and basically
what we assume is that we want to do
linear signal processing on our two
kinds of signals that are of interest
for us so we have a set of reproduction
channel U and we have a set of signals
set that we want to extract and if you
think of the inputs and outputs to this
digital signal processing unit here you
have these loudspeaker signals as
outputs and the retrieved signals as
input as other set of outputs so we put
those two in the output vector and we
did as this should all be linear signal
processing we assume that a set of input
signals you and another set of
microphone signals X's processed as
inputs and this Chi captures all the
linear signal processing which is of
course multiple input multiple output
then you can look at this G in terms of
sub matrices connecting these inputs the
reproduction channels and the microphone
signals individually and so you have
these four sub matrices which we will
look using the following to describe the
problem and then the gay the goal is
essentially to provide the desired
listeners signals at the ears here and
if you describe this in terms of linear
Systems Theory you will you see you have
the convolution of the loudspeaker
signals with the acoustic environment
this MIMO system described by this
matrix here but and you have the
additional noise this W of course
captures two signals prayer listener in
our case and on the other hand we have
the microphone signals and our X which
are basically a mixture of the source
signals convolved by the acoustic
environment the Impala
responses again plus the acoustic echo
resulting from the loudspeakers
transmitted via the acoustic environment
plus the noise vector and X that's for
the noise second and and one of the
problems or one of the reasons why this
is a problem at all is that the
acoustics can be quite nasty so all the
elements in our matrices here H they are
basically impulse responses and usually
you characterize them by a reverberation
time and this is the time the sound
needs to decay by 60 DB if it's if you
refer to T 60 and this is in karst
approximately 50 milliseconds and in
concert halls it reaches up to one to
two seconds
whenever you want to model these impulse
responses you take usually F IR signal
filters with a number of coefficients
that is typically T 60 times the
sampling frequency divided by three that
cut captures basically 20 D enough
energy so that you the model errors
below 20 DB these models are inherently
non minimum phase and if you look at
typical impulse responses here and you
look at pole 0 diagram you see most of
the zeros are actually on the unit
circle so in this case it's an it's an
impulse response recorded in an office
with the T 60 of about 300 milliseconds
at the sampling rate of 12 kilohertz
this is the impulse response and you
have actually thousands of zeros on or
very close to the unit circle which
tells something about how to deal with
this in order to for example D
reverberate a it or also equalize it
yeah from the Micra from the source to
the microphone that is non minimum phase
right it's not it's not nothing
it's non-minimum faces any flat delay is
not meaning face okay so it if we look
now at the the problems that we have to
solve given these acoustic environments
then we of course in reproduction want
to look at the desired signals at the
ears so basically we what what we want
to do is we want to create a set of
desired signals W D here which is of
course related only to the reproduction
channels by some matrix H D and this is
basically the desired matrix that we
have to provide in the end and if we
equate this to the actual path from the
reproduction channels to the ears then
we have to essentially equate this HD to
this term here and you see in order to
provide this you can have to deal with
the noise of course you still have the
noise of the years and there's a handle
to that you can use the microphone
signals and of course the as a second
component you see that the path for you
must be the desired path and this is in
reality this acoustic part and the one
sub matrix that you have to condition
the reproduction the signals that are to
be reproduced this gvu so we have
essentially two subproblems one is an
equalization problem which you may look
at as a deconvolution problem so this
unit must equalize this acoustic path in
order to achieve the desired
characteristic and the second problem is
an interference compensation problem
which basically means you have to use
these microphone signals and create an
estimate of the noise at the ears that
can be fed into the loudspeakers and of
course this also has to account for this
acoustic path obviously this is not so
simple and because you have to
mentally identify the acoustics here
between the loudspeaker in the
microphone and also you have to identify
the noise component at the ears which is
also non-trivial this is a real
challenge and all the active noise
cancellation approaches we know so far
always assume that they can measure the
noise is close to the ears but this is
in practice in our decide environment
not possible because we want to be
seamless and people should not need to
wear any devices close to the years ok
let me briefly look at the
state-of-the-art in reproduction and you
just in terms of this description if you
look at conventional sterian
multi-channel systems there is nothing
like interference compensation and also
equalization does not consider the real
acoustics it only considers something
which you may look like as a listener
you boost the basis or change the
amplification in various frequency bands
so you have frequency selective gains
but no accounting for the acoustics if
you look at beamforming with
loudspeakers that can be done either in
a more conventional way and/or super
directive beamforming ultra also ultra
sound based but still there is no
interference compensation so far and
also there is often only a course room
equalization for a sweet spot but not
for a whole extended area where people
white want to move while listening what
can be done and it's done actually in
some products already is that they use
impulse responses for the desired
characteristic already and so that this
there is a rough equalization already
but there is no room characteristics
inversion or equalization directly the
furthest we come so far is Rayfield
synthesis and there are first attempts
for interference compensation
so actually ahem Koons started to work
on this in 2004 but most of the time in
practical environments it's too
not possible to for example follow the
time variance of the acoustic
environment
and the on the other hand there are some
results on equalization but also only
for time invariant room acoustics and
such as pores works on that for about 4
years now but most of the time this is
also even in Bayfield centers is just a
set of impulse responses that use are
used for the reproduction channels in
order to mimic sound artificial rooms
without accounting for the real
listening environment so you can listen
to sounds like in churches but you don't
really invert the local listening
acoustics ok they are quite a few
challenges involved with that one of is
the equalization and the other is the
interference compensation in both if you
want to do it correctly perfectly Allah
require blind identification of these
acoustics and this is something which is
still pretty far out of reach I would
say but it's of course a nice challenge
for academia one problem however is that
many people argue we may not need that
actually we don't need that much spatial
realism we don't we may not really need
all the identification problem which is
highly sensitive to errors and we
publish papers on that how sensitive
that is so it's really questionable how
much spatial realism can we really
appreciate and this is one of the
questions that is still open in this
area and so it may be that's also one of
the reasons why not so much effort is
devoted to the sky even he could
identify us
it's minimal face you can't invert it
right you have to have an estimate for
that yes the listeners are usually not
really sensitive to all pass filtering
and you know any filter can be
decomposed in all paths and a minimum
phase system so then it would be
sufficient to equalize the minimum face
part so you cannot perfectly identify
that in many cases right but if you have
a good guess for the old pass filter
that might be sufficient okay let me
turn to the signal acquisition part and
this is where we are quite sure that
it's reasonable to identify the systems
that we need to identify here the
problem is that we essentially want to
extract a set of desired signals out of
this acoustic scene and they should be
undistorted in the sense that they
should sound as if you put a microphone
very close to the mouth here and remove
all other effects so if you compare this
to what you really get of course you
have these microphone signals as I said
this is a mixture of the source
components the acoustic echo and the
noise and this can be treated now by
using your other inputs namely the
reproduction channels and of course this
then you have these two sub matrices chi
zu & cheese EDX this one and this one to
treat this the microphone signals and to
get what you actually want to get this
results in essentially three sub
problems one is the acoustic echo
cancellation problem so where you
essentially need to model this acoustic
path including those matrices here by
this matrix and once you create those
two passes then of course the acoustic
echo is gone then basically what you
want to do so you want to remove all
components that are related to your
production channels the second problem
is the source separation or empty
reverberation problem that essentially
treats that these components resulting
from the desired sources so what you get
here at the my
your phone is the set of these the
mixture of all the desired sauces each
convolved with the acoustic path impulse
response and you can treat that with the
matrix cheese set X and what the result
should be basically a flat delay of the
desired sources and finally you would
like to suppress all the interfering
noises and this means essentially that
this matrix should nullify all the noise
components this looks very simple but of
course cheesy X has also to fulfill this
and to fulfill this so this is basically
a problem that this Chi set X needs to
satisfy all of them all of the
requirements and of course one of the
problems that you don't see so easily is
that first of all you would have to
separate all these these various
components in the microphone signals and
this is also to be done by G okay now in
the after talking so much about problems
I would like to come a little bit to a
few solutions one is the multi-channel
acoustic echo cancellation and here we
start with an isolated single channel
case in order to define the problem
again
essentially this is a textbook problem
since 25 years it has been recognized as
such and what you have to do is you find
an a filter which mimics the impulse
response via the loudspeaker the
acoustics in the microphone in order to
remove the components of you you do this
as you know this acoustic environment is
time variant by an adaptive filter which
usually approximates the VF solution I'm
sorry for using second-order statistics
here but this is quite appropriate and
has been working for many years also we
actually use some higher order
statistics in robust filtering as well
but is for here it's sufficient to
assume we have adaptive filters that
approximate a venous solution and why is
this a problem at all why do people talk
about it and I've seen a talk by
Microsoft people at I wink
the problems on implementing this it's a
long filter right in typically to get 20
DB echo suppression in a conference room
at 12 kilohertz sampling rate still asks
for 1,000 or more coefficients in the
living room it's easily four thousand
coefficients you would like to realize
in order simply to mimic this model this
acoustic path the multi-channel case is
a little more complex because of two
reasons the one is you have of course
obviously if you have K loudspeakers you
have K times more filter coefficients to
adapt which makes the problem
computationally more expensive but the
real problem for academia is of course
that they couldn't the autocorrelation
matrix here which is decisive for the
adaptation speed and the adaptation
behavior of the adaptive filters is
worse conditioned than in the single
channel case and I try to illustrate
this here by this matrix in the single
channel case you see and diagonal
dominant matrix and this matrix is the
autocorrelation matrix of these state
variables of the F IR filter and usually
it's at least diagonal dominant because
also speech has a decaying the
correlation of it so this would be look
like this if you have three channels
most of these channels are correlated so
you can easily match in in stereo a 5.1
the individual channels are strongly
correlated and then the autocorrelation
matrix of the set of all input vectors
for all these filters looks more or less
like this and if you're just infer
visually there's a lot of regularity and
you find columns and rows which are very
similar because the diagonal of the
diagonals in the off diagonal matrices
are still similar to the main diagonal
so this matrix is usually pretty
ill-conditioned there are a couple of
solutions to these two problems
regarding the cross correlation between
the channels yeah there are basically
only bad solutions so whatever you do
it's somehow
affecting your loudspeaker signals
because correlation is something you
cannot remove by linear time-invariant
processing so you have choices either
you add some non-linearity here and of
course this must be inaudible and
unfortunately the more inaudible it is
the less it helps right but that's quite
natural and you can add noise in the
same holds right so you should use it
below the masking threshold of the ear
so that people buying very expensive
audio equipment $20,000 loudspeaker
equipment they should not hear any noise
right but it still must be strong enough
to Decorah late the signals which is a
dilemma right
the third one and we think this is the
best solution is to introduce
time-varying all pass filtering which
are tuned such that the the perceived
sources don't move in space so you have
different all passes here they are time
varying so actually they slightly move
the sources if you have a stereo
reproduction you would think that if you
change the faces of the sort the signals
the the sources start to move actually
they do but they do it only to the
extent that you cannot hear it
perception so your binaural hearing is
not as high resolving that high that you
can hear that and this is actually done
with the audio coding people so you see
your inheres name here he was an intern
at that time with us and then we
developed this method and we think and
we published that actually I had I cast
2008 or 77 we this works actually quite
well so this is one way of playing dirty
tricks to resolve this correlation
problem and here is the solution or at
least one solution to the complexity
issue you essentially go to the DFT
domain and that results in this case of
in the fact that rather than
vertically etre sees you only in invert
many matrices of small size we think of
five channels and four thousand
coefficients in each channel so that's a
twenty thousand by twenty thousand
matrix is not to be inverted but you
rather invert four thousand matrices of
size five by five and this is
essentially what you do in real time
then so if you look at the results then
you feel that you can obtain reasonable
convergence much better of course than
an LMS here is a convergence curve for
the system ever announced which tells
you how well we identify the real
impulse responses and you get a
reasonable convergence with this
generalized frequency domain adaptive
filtering which have a Putin and others
proposed and this is here for two to
five channels over time you see the
convergence is pretty slow because this
is seconds what you really here is
actually the echo return loss
enhancement and this is the suppression
of the actual echo which converges much
faster to a level of about 20 DB in two
seconds now it's this needless to say
that we claim that the reproduction
quality with our time varying all pass
filters is still much better than the
others and we actually verified that by
moosh Ritesh but i would like to play an
example here and i hope the audio works
now so this is a microphone signal and
it actually is recorded for distance
speech recognition tasks some of you who
know german will identify that
DUI charges itself belong in our this
microphone signal trying to decent will
fit their house
quite the opposite safety a common
that's not you know one is no no let's
have a Buettner feed your uncharted bit
be long at our teaser film sign it isn't
filled bit off bus convoy to our Pentium
set TF l he cream is common sorry okay
that's basically the effect you could I
hope you could hear the conversions in
the beginning and you get down to easily
30 DB of echo suppression I cook
translation there is no post filter
involved for those of you and locate
post filtering you can do better even
but for at this in this application it's
still liquid part this is there's no
suppressor it's no just their filter
it's just their v channel filter so you
could even do better of course but you
would not hear that in this application
okay sorry Musha this is simply an
perceptual test with where you take in
this case about a dozen people to listen
and you have hidden anchors where you
know so you have ideal reference signals
and then you bring relative to that okay
there is a real time implementation
running on a PC and this is actually
quite old already so it was about five
years ago when we implemented that first
on a PC so nowadays pcs are much faster
and but still at that time already we
had could realize 20,000 coefficients so
what we're doing right now is a little
more challenging it is going from five
channel to more and in this case you see
a mic a loudspeaker array of 48 channels
for wave field synthesis and Herbert
Bortner actually and published
generic concept for wave domain adaptive
filtering in 2004 which essentially
transforms the problem into this another
domain namely the wave domain the idea
is here that you do not identify the
individual channels from each
loudspeaker to each microphone but you
decompose the wave field which is
generated by the wave field synthesis
into the into the harmonics in this case
cylindrical harmonics of the space so
it's essentially its Bessel functions in
the end and this transform comes first
and then you go to the DFT domain and
basically what you do is it say if in a
set up with 48 loudspeakers and 48
microphones rather than identifying 48
squared adaptive filters for identifying
all the elements in this acoustic matrix
then you only need to identify K in this
case 48 acoustic passes for the
according to the wave field
decomposition in terms of the
cylindrical harmonics so essentially you
bring down the computation complexity
from K Square to K actually a little
more than K but that actually works
quite well we had papers in the early
stage and simulated data but be an
output about to implement this in real
time hardware as well so nevertheless
this is an ideal environment in the
sense that the geometry of the
loudspeaker array is quite simple and
nice to handle because then the
cylindrical harmonics tell you how to do
this do and how to implement this
transform but the real challenge is is
to go to say listening spaces like your
living room at home where you don't want
to have a cylindrical array or a
circular array you want to build the
loudspeakers into the walls and then you
need other transforms and that makes it
really hard so that's still unsolved
but that's something to look forward to
then
the second topic and I I hope I don't
run out of time is the second topic is
on beamforming
that we use for signal extraction and
interference suppression and I have to
say we are not explicitly looking for
speech recognition application here but
we did use it for speech recognition as
well basically if you look at it it's
simply a signal separation task so you
have this box here and you would like to
separate those signals and that means
you can use three domains either time
frequency or space of course space
requires more than one sensor here if
the origin of the signal is known and
that may be either in time frequency or
space then they're separable 'ti is only
determined by the aperture which
basically time frequency resolution or
spatial resolution that's what
determines how well you can create the
signals but and if the origin of the
signal is unknown in these three domains
then you can talk about blind signal
separation so in reducing this to the
spatial dimension you have the
supervised beam forming for the case
that the spatial origin is known and you
have the kick for the case that the
spatial origin is unknown the blind beam
forming a blind source separation and
actually the both terms have been used
but blind source separation sounds more
fancy and then most people forget that
it's essentially blind beam forming let
me start with supervised beam forming
briefly and is what we see here is just
an example for a signal independent
filter in some beam form which in the
conventional way which should just be
understood as an example what you want
to achieve it looks at zero degrees so
that's the steering angle and it's eight
microphones and actually this can be
implemented directly on the microphone
array as you have seen it on the laptop
the spacing is four centimeters and what
we used here was a plain dove chebyshev
design a buffer certain frequency
which is about 1,200 Hertz here and then
from then on you have a nearly constant
beam with main lope and but at low
frequencies you see the spatial
resolution deteriorates drastically
please note this is sensitivity this
frequency this is space and/or angular
range and you see the low selectivity
with the low frequencies in the
conventional case the way to overcome
this is often seen as a different way of
beam forming but essentially it's not a
different way it's just providing
different filters to the individual
microphone channels and then you talk
about super directive beam forming it's
still signal independent and it's still
signal independent filters and for the
same geometry you see on this heat plot
that you can get a much better
resolution at low frequencies while
still preserving the constant beam with
around zero degree here this example
actually is due to frequency invariant
beam former proposed by power and the
problem here is actually that in the low
frequency region you get very sensitive
to incoherent noise and calibration
errors of your microphones and actually
and that's not on the slides here but we
recently developed a method which
incorporates basically constraints on
the sensitivity here into directly into
the beam format design so that for a
given sensitivity you can in one shot
the design the beam former perfectly the
third kind of beam forming I would like
to put forward here is actually a robust
version of the generalized sight low
Consular which we used for speech
recognition as well and actually it was
not mentioned on your slide so it would
be nice to compare the recognition
results with yours but it as John
already mentioned basically what you do
here and you may remember this block
diagram is
a constraint beamforming with a minimum
squared ever construe criterion so it's
a second-order statistics based
criterion in the in its original version
but you can easily use other
optimization criteria with the problem
of estimating the higher-order
statistics the basic idea is here you
minimize the output with the constraint
that the desired source should not be
distorted and for that in the clever
idea of the SiteLock translates actually
that the two problems are decomposed so
you have the constraint realized up here
and the you have an unconstrained
adaptation down here so that makes it
really efficient but what's important in
the acoustic domain is that you adapt
the blocking matrix as well to get good
quality the plucking matrix namely has
to provide an output signal which is a
good estimate of the noise and if this
desired source moves here then it's
important that this that this blocking
matrix does not allow any leakage of the
desired signal because this would the
interfere cancel interference consulate
which is placed here would then cancel
out the desired signal from here as well
this is actually quite a problem which
you need to avoid so this is why I write
here the adaptive blocking matrix is
actually quite important and in order to
make this converging quite rapidly even
under double-talk situation so we're
both interferer and desired source are
active it's advisable to use it in
adaptation in the FT domain again and I
will play you an audio example for this
here so first you here is signal
microphone with a two into two sources
one is the interferer and it's at an SI
R of three DB here and it's actually
the lake for the first years but sorry
so let's listen to the output of the
fixed beam farmer and please note that
the low frequencies usually cannot be
suppressed well because this here is the
fixed beam format like you've seen it a
couple of slides ago this one up this
one right and it does not suppress low
frequency content well harry hagrid of
course was still flashing his way across
the lake but the first years buddy
app and now finally the output including
the effect of the interference counselor
which should reduce the low frequency
interfering noise interfering speech as
well Harry looked up at the staff table
there seemed to be rather more empty
sits there than usual Hagrid of course
was still fighting his way across the
lake but the first years okay and if you
measure this you can have an SAR gain of
about 17 DB here but as you could see
already there is still a challenge here
especially if you go to Haile
reverberant environments and so as John
pointed out already in there this way of
this version of beamforming does not
cope completely successfully with
reverberation if it does not have enough
degrees of freedom by way of many
microphones so let me move over to the
blind part of the core of this talk
where and I will focus only on the 20
count concept which has been developed
in my group and first of all I'd like to
look at source separation and then
briefly Adi reverberation but also at a
localization and especially localization
of multiple sources and even in multiple
dimensions and we'll see in a minute
what this means so first of all the
blind source separation scenario is
given here so you see multiple sources
multiple microphones we assume that the
number of sources and the my number of
microphones is equal and we are looking
for a D missing matrix here Chi said X
that's actually the same building block
that we had in the previous but now it's
meant for D mixing and what you
essentially want is you want to extract
the desired sources here so if you
ideally achieve that that would mean you
had to invert this acoustic mixing
matrix and then you would get a simply a
delayed version of the original signal
this is not what blind source separation
does actually blind source separation
does not blind deconvolution
rather it only tries to minimize the
mutual information between the output in
the best case so the strongest criterion
that you can fulfill for blind source
separation is that the minimum mutual
information between the outputs is
minimized
trinny con actually clinic on provides a
framework which essentially describes
this criterion the minimum mutual
information criterion and is especially
designed for a non whiteness non
stationarity and non Gaussian ET of the
source signal and if you look at the
cost function for PSS here it's actually
20 con is more generic and can be used
for other like purposes like
localization and do reverberation as
well but if you look at the cost
function for BSS you try to minimize the
mutual information for between these
outputs by looking at dense multivariate
densities of each of these outputs so
here for example you have the log of
estimated D dimensional densities for
each outputs for each output so just
imagine you take D variables here and
you look at the multivariate density of
these D output samples of one channel
then you multiply all of these D
multivariate outputs so that means the
independence of the individual outputs
and you contrast this to the joint
density over all the output values over
all the channels this is basically the
idea so
of course if you write this down as a
cost function you don't have an
algorithm yet how to achieve the best
filter coefficients but this is
basically the underlying idea for blood
for BSS and there is some averaging here
which allows you to cope with non
stationarity and also here you have a
recursive averaging so yeah yeah it
seems like this with me you made the
assumption that you only have two
sources but it seems that that approach
was sensitive to noise I did not mention
that estimating these probability
densities is of course very difficult in
general if you we know we all know there
are higher the order of the moment you
estimate the more sensitive its to noise
and of course if you just think of
estimating kurtosis it's a fourth order
moment but the fourth order moment
already has an a variance of the
estimate to the eighth power right so
you're exploding in sensitivity right
you can use parametric models of course
but this is still the generic idea so
whatever you can put into that as models
that will help and we will go to come to
this but this basically is the starting
point and everything is basically
derived from that by specialization and
the first in simple case that you would
look at is second order statistics which
essentially means you assume Gaussian
densities also you may know that these
are not representing speech signals well
but nevertheless it's a way to start and
then you know for example that the that
these curve these high dimensional
densities can be captured and this
entirely described by correlation
matrices and that helps again so then
you the sort is the source model is just
a multivariate Gaussian then you have
simply the correlation matrix to
consider and that also actually leads to
a relatively simple adaptation algorithm
the natural gradient for example can be
computed from the cost function then so
if you reduce the cost function to
second-order statistics you can compute
the natural gradient and you have a
relatively simple update rule and if you
look at this here it actually means you
have to invert a matrix very similar to
our eighth errorless to recursively
square C's to illustrate what we do here
is you see these correlation matrices
for the two-channel case it actually
whatever we saw said above holds for the
p-channel case but this is for the
two-channel case so if you don't do
anything and you just look at the
observed mixtures at the microphones you
would see correlation matrices like this
for each Channel and you would see cross
correlation matrices like these off
diagonal matrices and these are of
course of the dimension that you foresee
for you do the mixing filters so if you
foresee the mixing filters of length
1,000 then you still have two thousand
by two thousand matrices here and what
the this algorithm would try to achieve
is to remove the cross correlation
between the channels which actually
means to nullify the off diagonal
matrices if you want to Deer evaporate
the signals a little then you would
remove also the outer correlation part
of these correlation matrices here
assuming that the inner correlation is
due to the speech model and the outer
part is due to the impulse response of
the filter and this is what we call
partial D convolution multichannel blind
partial D convolution here and if you
completely want to whiten your output
signals then you would perform a
completely convolution that's here a
multi-channel blind deconvolution then
this matrix would be diagonal again
there is and real-time implementation
actually since 2004 and we continuously
worked on improving it and it's for P
equals to 2 channels on a PC and/or were
tightener I saw him
while ago is his gun in the mean time
but he's the one who supervised the
master CC student who implement that it
implemented that in real time and there
is still a lot to be done and it's no
secret anymore that we work on that for
hearing aids where there are rock turns
and heavy constraints but even without
the heavy constraints of this
application the reverberation is still a
problem and especially the case where
you have more sources than sensors if
you think of a cocktail party effect
where you actually have only two hearing
aids in two years which may be linked by
an orally but you still don't are not
able to deal with ten sources so there's
still a lot to be done but there is some
progress under way and we will publish
very soon on that gradients which we
have had a not a Gaussian circular
process
within your process you will see this in
habit weakness PhD thesis Oh finally I
hope okay
okay anyway I would like to give you an
impression of what we can achieve in for
the three channel case actually so as I
said twin econ is a relatively generic
scheme and whatever is and this is
actually only one branch which already
makes the assumption that we can
describe all this sources by SERPs
which is exactly what you mentioned by
the guy
MIOSHA Geechee function so this is a way
of creating multivariate densities based
on single variate densities and
extending that relatively simply and
then you have you see you have the one
branch for the multivariate cautions and
you have another branch where you have
univariate PDFs and this is basically
branches where you see all the or the
most of the common BSS techniques
aligned so this is actually a more
generic scheme which has these as
special cases and Robert Eisner actually
developed an relatively efficient
version for multivariate gaussians which
I want to play here you will see the
sensor signals or listened here the
things of signals first and if you
listen to the output of the BSS scheme
okay finished just read it through if it
sounds all right in conclusion for the
interest of all concerned
they must point out that for ecological
reasons alone we glad
he grant your request however you should
prove that you are in a position to keep
your word
all in all your ideas sound very
convincing okay I guess you could hear
the initial convergence phase a bit let
me play that the other one daddy listen
to what I can do already 1 times 1
equals 1/2 times 2 equals 4 3 times 3
equals 9 4 times 4 equals 16 5 times 5
equals 25
6 times 60 sake of time I don't play the
females but but anyway what you get if
you measure that the performance it's
about 19 DB in separation gain and one
of the important features here is which
I'd like to emphasize you basically have
no distortion of the desired source so
you can it there is a slight calibration
but there is no distortion like you have
it usually in noise suppression t with
noise suppression techniques in spectral
subtraction ok so let me move over to
the reverberation and the reverberation
is here considered or depicted as a
single channel problem we actually look
at it in the multi channel problem and
in the multi channel setting but the
main idea is here really that do you
consider this speech signal as being a
correlated signal where the the first
part of the correlation is due to the
vocal tract and the rest is due to the
room characteristics which means you
would like to preserve these diagonals
in the in the cross correlation matrix
and you would like to get rid of the
outer diagonals that's relatively simple
idea but it's relatively hard to put
this into an efficient adaptive
algorithm so because it asked for
another constraint in the adaptation
nevertheless you can do this and please
note as in the blind source separation
context we use filters of length 1000 at
the sampling rate of 16 kilohertz
here we have again two source two
channels and the nice thing about this
scheme is that it of course does
separation and D reverberation at the
same time and actually this the
separation is even improved relative to
the Mir PSS algorithm and the D
reverberation is also clearly stronger
than with for example delay in some beam
format but of course if you only have
two mics the delay in some beam from it
will not give you much I am not sure
whether you can hear the effect in this
room because the the original signal is
not too reverberant either but let's try
we will achieve a more vivid sense of
what it is by realizing what it is not
it's not easy to create illuminating
examples the side ones are half inch
narrower we will achieve a more vivid
sense of what it is by realizing what it
is not it's not easy to create
illuminating examples the side ones are
half inch narrower we will achieve a
more okay so basically this is how far
you get without any extra measures
without any subtraction and post
filtering or equalization of the
spectrum this is really what comes out
of the turn econ algorithm and of course
if you feel that there's any coloration
you can still equalize that let me look
at localization briefly and see I'm
almost running out of time but we're
getting close okay we can use this blind
scheme for look localization of multiple
sources as well and the idea is
essentially again relatively simple
because if you consider this source here
and the effort that is done by the D
mixing matrix in BSS it means that if
you want to separate these two sources
from each other and you want to get s 1
here you need to identify filters here
in these 2 passes which essentially I
then are equal to these two channels so
this acoustic channel
should be modeled by this one and this
one should be modeled by this filter so
if you look then at these filters and
look at the main Peaks you will find the
direct acoustic paths and the peaks of
the acoustic paths tell you the relative
delay between the two signals and that
is an indication of the direction of
arrival and then you can basically find
the local the source location that's how
is simple as long as you have only two
sources and it can actually be seen as a
generalization of the adaptive
eigenvalue decomposition algorithm that
pennis t published in ninety nine if you
have more than two sources then you can
compute something like directivity
patterns at the output of these of the
BSS scheme and these zeros that you will
find they point to the suppressed
sources and the only averaged over
several directivity patterns and you get
a pattern of all the suppressed sources
and the suppressed sources will tell you
the locations so that's basically an TOA
estimator and that works in the over
determined case as well so that's the
case when you have more sir sources than
you have microphones you can also
generalize this to multiple dimensions
because if usually localization is only
seen in a plane as a problem but of
course sometimes you want to be
three-dimensional and then you simply
come a combine several PSS units maybe
one in the vertical plane and one in the
horizontal plane and the nice thing
about PSS is that at these outputs you
have the original signals being
separated sources so it's relatively
easy to correlate these outputs and for
example resolve all kinds of ambiguities
which you would get if you have a set of
angles for your desired sources in one
plane and another set of angles in the
vertical plane you would not now know
how to align those but with the signals
to to correlate here if you take these
signals and correlate in them in the two
Planes then you find the proper pairs of
angles nevertheless there is still a lot
to be done because we are also
interested in making this scheme
reacting very fast to short acoustic
events that means for example two shots
or two glasses falling down and then you
usually don't have enough time to
converge to reliable solutions right and
that's basically what we do anyway so we
have I don't talk about implementation
for a certain implications but you would
have at least for localization as you
say shorter filters and then you're of
course converging faster but the result
is not as reliable as you like to have
it so of course that's the way to go but
it's still not solving the problem
completely because we reliability
suffice okay so let me finally go to
localization in of multiple sources in
another domain namely in the wave domain
and that brings me to the nice little
array that Heinz torch built a while ago
where we combine basically our idea of a
field analysis that means describing the
acoustic the acoustic wave field in
terms of cylindrical harmonics with the
techniques that are known from array
processing namely the subspace methods
notre usually these subspace methods are
meant and most effective for narrowband
signals but of course we deal with
wideband signals and fortunately the
very fill decomposition gives us a
description of the wave field which can
be handled as if it were a narrowband so
we can apply these methods here and we
use a
cylindrical harmonics and this is very
close to what Gary Elko proposes as
Aikman beams in when he uses beamforming
when he uses these arrays for
beamforming but we use it for source
localization and actually you then we
use the typical algorithms for subspace
localization that is music or Esprit
actually espree turns out to be much
better for our case and that allows us
essentially to localize M minus 1
sources if we M minus 1 sources
simultaneously and M defines the number
of selector harmonics that we consider
and actually we could localize up to 5
sources here with this arrangement and
this is a very small device as I said
about 10 centimeters in diameter again
this is not complete because these
subspace methods are also assuming
stationary sources and you have to be
quite reliable in estimating the your
covariance matrices but if and if you
can't do that then you have to find some
improvement on the algorithms to deal
with non stationarity we are on this
road but we are not yet at the gold so
it and it's not yet solve completely and
finally again reverberant environments
are another problem which is not
completely solved here it works in
mildly reverberant rooms but not in
strongly reverberant rooms if you put it
in here it would probably work this is
not a bad environment for that purpose
if especially if you put the microphone
away onto the ceiling here that would
work but if you go to a nastier
environment like train stations or large
halls then this doesn't work so far so
let me conclude what I wanted to show
here is the plain acoustic human machine
interface still offers a number of major
challenges but which can both seen as
signal separation and system
identification tasks and
the reason why this is still a problem
is the acoustic environment which we
deal with is highly complex in terms of
number of degrees of freedom and it's
time variance and also in the natural
environment in this for these natural
interfaces we usually miss the reference
signal so we have many blind problems
and this is one of the main things and
here is the list of what we've been
looking at so far multi-channel acoustic
echo cancellation beamforming source
separation D reverberation and
localization this basically concludes my
talk but I would like to add to John's
statement reverberant environments are
really still one of the many challenges
which we have and that's the ones that
we want to resolve in the future that we
see as the next major task and we have
been working for that on that for a
while now but we are still pretty far
away from perfect solutions that's just
what the world of this kind of
singapore's tangley are they going to go
to this top human aid in the mainstream
or it is something already human you
mean work to which kind of processing is
going into giving it I don't I cannot
talk too much but suddenly hearing aids
are a very interesting area and it's
highly constrained and it does not allow
for any imperfections in speech quality
so hearing aid manufacturers will not
allow us a strong noise suppression with
artifacts that you will not be good
the cellphone allows much more say
artifacts and whatever is cheap will be
bought right so it's it's a bit
different but nevertheless we are not
only focusing on hearing it because all
the wave field synthesis stuff of course
is obviously not suited for a field
Center for hearing aids so but blind
source separation is obviously something
which is very well at fit to hearing
aids because the blindness does not only
mean you're blind for the source
positions you are also blind for the
sensor positions and this is actually a
feature that is important for hearing
aids because hearing aid wearers
will not type in the distance between
the microphones first or the say the
direction the look direction of their
smaller race they have behind each year
right so that's you for these algorithms
for binaural algorithms you're actually
blind with respect to the sensor
positions as well it's very small there
are a couple of issues I referred only
to two microphones in the blind source
separation problem but of course
nowadays hearing aids have up to three
mics in each at each ear right and they
are very closely spaced they are highly
super directive beam former right and so
there are a couple of issues in the
interaction of those with beam for with
blind source separation for example but
this is I would say that's right that's
a very specific area one comment one
question
so
we tried out to the Austrian water as
well as before
developed by your student hopefully
before going yeah if it were the same we
wouldn't have published it right I say
the same but we tried it out and we were
sort of embarrassed because we couldn't
publish the results because they weren't
better than the MMSE being over and that
depends on how you implement and MMS is
a flexible criterion if you put the
constraint into it then it's different
different criterion so you if you take a
plane MMSE beam former you don't have
the constraint in it right
the question was okay you see even the
comment that they wrote the
reverberation is different from the
secret speech separation right or a
source separation but there's this
result from from the ICA world and they
show that essentially negative P is
related to mutual information yeah
that's a my thought about them if you
minimize mutual information you're
essentially maximizing the neck entropy
right that's right that you saw from my
results that reverberation increases
negatively
I'm sorry decreasing deep yeah that's
but this is a byproduct I would say it
actually well let's see go away if you
consider non-gaussian statistics know if
you look at this here so this is the
cost function right so that's this that
describes mutual independence between
the outputs right now if you want to do
reverberate right then you have to put
into these estimated densities source
model for years for your signal and the
model for your reverberation in each
channel right then you can describe this
as a say a multivariate density with a
separate term for the source model and a
separate term for the deliver for the
impulse response right there's a result
from the I see a world that shows that
if you enforce the constraint that the
final sources the sources that you
separate must be D correlated yeah
then maximizing negatory minimizing
neutral that's also scale any things we
are not talking about Scylla mixings
yeah demonstrated that when you
reverberate a signal yeah it becomes
more Gaussian this is this case if I
used my dimension D here to one right so
that's a special case if you go here to
one then you're fine
but this is explicitly not done here
because we know that our outputs are
correlated signals and this and we treat
them in the time domain right the cost
function is derived in the time domain
the implementation is done in the
frequency domain we don't care right we
can do anything in the DFT domain as
long as we are careful right but you
have to be careful of course but
nevertheless the cost function is on the
time domain samples and then you do go
to the frequency domain for
implementation purposes and that is it
this is a very very fundamental part of
this concept unlike all these I am
getting nasty now I'm sorry
see here is the unconstraint eft domain
PSS world and here is a block which I
see as a dark hole where you do all
kinds of repair mechanisms to for
example resolve the ambiguity problem
and and this is your I'll I don't want
to discard these algorithms in principle
but they are all they all set D equal to
one and then they need something to
realign the frequency bins right and
that basically can sometimes bring you
back as in the power domain to a model
which is essentially in line with
starting unit with univariate PDFs and
so on so you can go back a little bit
but many of the algorithms are really
using repair mechanisms correlation
between frequency bins and so on